I know what you did bachelor nation grab  your glass it's time for roses and roses  roses and Rose Day is et's weekly  bachelor franchise recap show airing  Tuesday's where we areas Lee Oh  dramatically my emotions my moods have  gone from low lows to hi hi why drink  every time wine review the latest in  bachelor nation  you know what through all of this muck  we've got to have a little light keeping  us going shining us through even  bringing you bachelor fans exclusive  bachelor nation news along the way  shrink every time somebody was  blindsided on this episode I choose you  today but I choose you every day from  here on out daring and of course  dramatic I have no time to discuss this  moving on it's roses and Rosie